FEMALE SPEAKER: I would like
to welcome to Google Anna
Quindlen.
Anna Quindlen is a household
name, beloved for her "New York
Times" best selling books, which
include eight novels and eight
works of nonfiction.
She was the third woman to have
a regular column in the "New
York Times" op-ed page.
And "Public and Private" won the
Pulitzer Prize for commentary
in 1992.
And for 10 years she wrote
the "Last Word" column
in "Newsweek."
Her eighth novel, "Miller's
Valley," was just released.
And we are so honored to
welcome her to Google today.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much
for being here.
I read that you
don't necessarily
like to read reviews of your
books, but "Miller's Valley"
is getting wonderful reviews.
So congratulations.
ANNA QUINDLEN: Well thank you.
I actually made it a point,
starting four books ago,
to not read any reviews,
positive or negative.
It just makes a lot
of noise in your head
when you sit down to
write the next one.
And I don't need any more
noise than is already up there.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you have
anyone else read for you?
ANNA QUINDLEN: My best
friend vets all the reviews.
She's actually a book
reviewer by profession.
And so mainly she just, oh
this one was really good.
And by the way, we hate
the people at whatever
the name of the magazine is.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's sounds
like a good way to do it.
It's a very soothing
way to do that.
I was wondering if, to begin,
if you might read a paragraph
from "Miller's Valley."
ANNA QUINDLEN: Now
you selected this one.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I did.
I selected this one.
I think it will ring very
true to a lot of people.
ANNA QUINDLEN: It was
a hard time in the fall
just before I turned 16.
August 2nd had come and gone
and Donald had never arrived.
He sent me a postcard saying
he couldn't get off work,
but his grandfather had already
told me he wouldn't be coming.
"It's that mother
of his," he said.
Don't get me started.
He looked so sad.
I knew how he felt. Our
house was built for five.
And now it was down to three.
My brother's old shirts
hung in their closets
like the ghosts of people
who'd once slept in their beds.
I missed Tommy.
I missed Donald.
I even missed Eddie sometimes
and Donald's grandmother.
Sometimes I thought
about her lavender smell
and her warm pies.
I think maybe more than anything
I missed the Mimi I used to be.
Getting older wasn't
working out so well for me.
My brother's words
had made me think
a lot about what I wanted,
where I wanted to end up.
And the truth was I had
no idea in the world.
I figured it should be
clear like that big strip
of yellow tape they held
across the end of the course
for the sack race at the
volunteer fire department
picnic.
This, here, this is how you win.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
I picked that paragraph
because I definitely
think that myself definitely,
and a lot of people,
think that it
should be clear, you
know the path we're supposed
to follow, and then it's not.
And as you can see from
my marks in the book,
you write a lot of
these human truths.
I've seen people refer
to it as the thoughts
that we didn't realize we had.
We have the emotions, but
we don't have the words.
And I was wondering how
you find those words.
ANNA QUINDLEN: Well that's one
of the great things about being
a writer.
Writing leads to more writing
leads to more writing.
People ask me all the
time about writer's block.
I was a newspaper
reporter for years.
And you can't have writer's
block in a newspaper newsroom.
You have to write whether
you feel like writing or not.
So I always sit down, even when
I feel at my least eloquent.
And I think what happens is
bad writing or mediocre writing
eventually sometimes
leads to good writing.
And good writing
leads to insight
into yourself and into
the human condition, that
even come as a shock to you.
I mean, sometimes I'll write
a sentence and rear back
and look at it and think, my
god, that is what I think.
I mean, that's the thing
that keeps you going,
because doing this is
like pushing a rock uphill
over and over again.
And it's those moments
where suddenly you
say to yourself, that's it.
I mean, there was a columnist
at the "New York Times," Scotty
Reston, and he once
said, "How can I
know what I think until
I read what I write?"
And I really feel
that way all the time.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I've
heard writing referred
to as an excavation process
more so than-- or I've heard
some people refer to it
as an excavation process
where you sort of have
to chip away at all
the thoughts and the words.
And then you reach what you're
really trying to get at.
ANNA QUINDLEN: Well, but
alternatively there's
a famous quote, and it's
been attributed to everyone
from the sports writer Red
Smith to Dorothy Parker.
"Writing is simple.
You just sit down at the
typewriter and open a vein."
And now I would say you
just sit down at the Mac Air
and open a vein, but you're
always opening a vein.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Speaking of
"Miller's Valley," so it's
the story of Mimi Miller
and we sort of grow with her
throughout the book.
And it's the story
of her and her family
and Miller's Valley,
this rural community.
And there's waters coming in.
The government is sort
of flooding her valley.
And the flood, you know,
when I first read the book,
the flood was just a flood.
But I think that there's
more to it than that.
And I was wondering
if you could speak
of the significance of
the flood in the story,
and then also what it means
to you outside the story.
ANNA QUINDLEN: Well
within the story,
it reflects what happened
all over this country
at various times in its history.
Not just with water,
but with other entities,
which is that the
government makes
a decision that the
land on which you live
might be better used
for the interstate
or a big industrial complex
or something of the sort,
the law of eminent domain
which we've all heard about.
And in this case, they
think Miller's Valley
would be the perfect
spot for a reservoir.
And the fact that there are
some family farms, which
have been in families for
decades if not centuries,
is not a bar, in their
mind, to progress.
Part of what I wanted
to reflect by that
is the price we
pay for progress.
Frequently progress means
wiping the past clean.
And I don't think that
there is much use to that.
I think the past is there to
be learned from, not to paper
over.
But obviously that's what the
government wants to do here.
The other thing in a larger
sense I was trying to reflect
is that I think
America in some ways
is uniquely a country that
disappears its past over
and over again.
And it's one of the
reasons why we continually
make the same
mistakes, because we
seem not to have learned
from what went before,
in part because we don't
remember what went before.
Someone was
interviewing me today
and said that the
writer Gore Vidal once
referred to our country as
the United States of Amnesia.
And I think there's
some truth to that.
And I wanted to reflect
that in the book.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And the flood in
the book, it's a slow process.
There comes a point
where Mimi realizes
what's happening when it sort
of passes the line of no return.
Do you think that
there's also something
there that these slow
processes that don't really
mean too much until we
realize that we can't go back?
ANNA QUINDLEN: Yeah.
I mean, I think if we're
going to lose our homes,
we lose them by inches.
And we lose them by inches
whether they're underwater
or they still sit there or not.
I mean, one of the things that I
think is reflected in this book
is the place where
Mimi grew up, the place
where she did all of the
learning that turned her
into who she is
as an older woman,
is now utterly disappeared.
You know, it's under 40 feet of
water by the end of the book.
But the truth is the
places where we all
grew up, for most of us, they
cease to exist a while ago.
I mean, even if
we're quite young,
the Walmart has
replaced the cornfield.
And the tattoo parlor has
replaced the card store
on Main Street.
And things morph and change.
Conversely, the place
where we all grew up
is vividly, completely,
utterly alive.
It's just completely
alive inside of us.
I mean, I haven't been back
to the house where I grew up
since I was 14 years old.
But I can tell you exactly
what kind of wallpaper
was on the walls of my room
and how to get to the kitchen
from the dining room
and all the rest.
So that notion of home
becoming part of you,
there's a quote from James
Baldwin at the beginning
of the novel that says,
"Home is not a place,
it's an irrevocable condition."
And I think that's true as well.
FEMALE SPEAKER: There's a line,
perhaps the most quoted line
of the book that's in many
reviews is, "No one ever
leaves the town where they
grew up, even if they go."
Do you think this has
a different meaning?
I'm far from my hometown.
But some people stay
close to their hometown
for their entire life.
And do you think, is
there a different meaning,
whether you stay--
you're close in distance,
or do you think it sort
of holds the same meaning?
ANNA QUINDLEN: I think it holds
the same meaning for everybody.
I think it sort of lives
inside you where you're from.
And all those years later
there are those little tells.
I've been a New Yorker
since I was 18 years old
and went to college in New York.
And today two women at
an event said to me,
I'm from Philadelphia too.
Well, I am from Philadelphia.
That's where I was
born and grew up.
So there's that part of your
home that shapes you so much
that it's always part
of where you're from.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
I've definitely been
told that my
Midwestern is showing
on a number of occasions.
Let's talk a bit
about your career.
How did you find
writing originally?
ANNA QUINDLEN: I'm a
writer because of teachers.
I was the kind of little girl
who got As in English and Ds
in conduct.
And yet whenever I would
hand in a composition or some
of the ham handed poetry
I wrote or the like,
some teacher would say to
me, this is really good.
I'm giving you an A. You
should keep doing this.
And when the single
most important adults
in your life--
after your parents--
tell you over and over again
that you're good at something,
you tend to continue doing it.
And I think I also
responded to it
so powerfully because from
the time I was very little,
the thing that I loved most in
the whole world, the thing that
gave me a sense that
I might actually
have a place in the world, even
though I was a girl growing up
in the 1950s and
'60s, was reading.
Reading was the thing
that introduced me
to women who got to do
so many of the things
that none of the
women I knew did.
And so loving reading
as much as I did,
the idea of actually
producing a book
was kind of
enormously seductive.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
how do you think--
you mentioned reading
books by women.
And how do you think being
a woman has influenced
your career and your life?
ANNA QUINDLEN: In
a variety of ways.
I actually wound up at
"The New York Times"
entirely because I'm female.
"The Times" had a
class action suit
brought against it charging that
it didn't pay, promote, or hire
women in parity with men.
And as part of
settling that suit,
they hired a whole lot
of us in 1977 and 1978.
I was a 24-year-old
tabloid reporter,
which was in no way, shape,
or form your typical "New York
Times" reporter.
And they hired me
because of that suit.
And they sort of pushed
me along pretty quickly
because of that suit,
so that I wound up
becoming an editor,
getting a column,
and then ultimately winding
up on the op-ed page
and becoming the youngest person
who had been an op-ed page
columnist.
So I really richly
benefited from being female.
And frankly I think
in some ways it
was an advantage as
a fiction writer too.
Women buy more than the lion's
share of hardcover fiction
in this country.
People say to me
sometimes, well how
do you feel about having
a large female audience?
I say, if I have a large
female audience, I am set.
So it's been mainly
a good thing for me.
But it's been mainly
a good thing for me
because, like Mimi
in the novel, I
was lucky enough to come of age
during second wave feminism.
So every year on
her birthday, I try
to remember to send Gloria
Steinem an email that
says thank you for my life.
Because I really believe that
if I had been born much earlier,
I would have been a
usually frustrated person
with many, many fewer
opportunities, if any.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You are
somewhat unique as an author
in that you've written
a lot of nonfiction
as well as a lot of fiction.
Is there a difference
in how you approach them
and how you write them
and your enjoyment
of the different styles?
ANNA QUINDLEN: Well, fiction is
more of a challenge for me now.
And the thing about
writing novels
is you're really starting
anew with every book.
You're sort of frightening
yourself with every book
because you're setting
yourself a new task.
But in terms of forcing yourself
to write when you don't feel
like writing, looking for
the telling detail that
communicates something to the
reader very quickly with just
a few words, keeping your prose
tight, writing sentences that
come out of people's mouths that
actually sound like words that
come out of people's mouths--
which is unfortunately
rarer in fiction
than one might like--
they're not so different.
The great thing about nonfiction
is if you hit a speed bump,
you can always go
to the notebook.
You know, oh, let's look
at the quotes on that.
Let's look at that story that
we found that's so great.
Oh, maybe a little bit of
data here, that kind of thing.
There's none of that in a novel.
It's all gotta come out
of the notebook that's
your imagination.
But a lot of the
craft is the same.
And my voice is not so very
different from one form
to another.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How do you
find-- in "Miller's Valley,"
Mimi has a very unique voice.
How do you write
different voices?
ANNA QUINDLEN: Writing
a first person novel
is a little bit of a challenge.
I mean getting the voice is
really where the action is.
I spend a lot of walking
around time before I ever
write the beginning of a novel.
I spend months during-- I
either walk or run for an hour
every morning.
And it looks like all I'm
doing is aerobic exercise,
but the truth is I do a lot
of work while I'm doing it.
And you know, I start to
think about a character
and what she looks like.
And over time if
I've convinced myself
that the novel is going to
be told in the first person,
I begin to get a sense of
her voice, of how she sounds.
She's a very down to earth,
pragmatic, plain spoken person.
And that gave me
keys to various ways
in which she would speak
that were really useful.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What
about your writing
sort of gives you life
and what other parts of it
that take life away?
Is it all wonderful,
or are there--
ANNA QUINDLEN: Oh,
none of it's wonderful.
It's all pretty painful
to be honest with you,
because you know, it's
especially important
to say this to students.
Writing as much as anything else
is an exercise in confidence.
I mean, people make it all
about nouns and verbs and voice.
And all of that is important.
But what it means to
sit at the computer
and write something
for which you
want to find readers
is that you have
to have an inner
voice that's saying,
I have something
really important to say
and people should listen to me.
And that's a huge psychological
leap for most of us to do that,
so that you're always fighting
that feeling that what you have
to say is not very interesting
and that there isn't anybody
out there who cares about it.
You're always fighting
that confidence battle,
it seems to me.
And people think that
the more you do this,
the less you have to
fight that battle.
And certainly you feel more
sure handed in certain ways.
But then you wind up
being up against yourself.
You know, I have a
friend who's involved
in the musical theater.
And he said, the more he did,
the more the reviews would say,
well, this isn't as
good as the last thing.
And so that's one of the reasons
why I don't read reviews too,
because the last thing
looms large when you're
trying to start over again.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What do you to
say to students or to anyone
who says, I really,
really want to write,
but I'm just so afraid to start.
How do you-- do you
have words that say?
ANNA QUINDLEN: It's
the Nike slogan.
Just do it.
I mean, the key to writing is
putting your butt in a chair.
But what I would say-- and it's
really important to say this
to, say, high
school students-- is
for some reason we've developed
this mindset in America
that if you're good at
something it's effortless.
And therefore people
say to me all the time,
oh, you must love to write.
It must come so easily to you.
And I think God, please
let that be true some day.
But the problem with
that is once they've
absorbed that notion,
students sit down to write
and they find it, as I
do, as most writers do,
challenging and difficult.
So they say to themselves,
it's not effortless for me.
Therefore I am not good at it.
So what I would say is that
virtually every writer I know,
including people who have won
the Pulitzer or the National
Book Award, even the Nobel,
find it infinitely challenging.
And that if you really
want to write, look,
there's two ways
of looking at this.
And the distinction
between them is important.
The student who says to
me, I would like to write.
And I say well, we'll talk.
And the student who comes to
me and says, I'm a writer.
If you're saying to
yourself, I'm a writer,
you just have to do it.
You just have to find
some way or another
to do it and still pay the rent,
which can be the hat trick.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Have you
ever-- has writing always
been the thing that
you wanted to do,
or sort of the avenue that
you wanted your life to be on.
Or have there been
other things that you
thought oh, that would be fun.
I would like to try that.
ANNA QUINDLEN: You
know, I always thought
that if I had two lives, if I
got to have two instead of just
one, I really would have
liked to practice medicine,
which is odd
considering the fact
that the only science course I
took in college was psychology.
But I know myself better
now and I know my strengths
and weaknesses better now.
But writing is just
one of those things--
I mean, as I just said,
not even after a while,
it's not so much what
you do as who you are.
It's the way you
order the world.
And that's been true for
me for a long, long time.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How
important do you
think the written word is,
both writing and reading?
I read a few of your
public and private columns,
and there was one on
enough bookshelves
that you wrote about your son
and his sort of excitement
in finishing, and then another
one on book censorship.
And it seems like
access to written word
is something that
you value highly.
ANNA QUINDLEN: It's the most
single most important aspect
of the democratic society,
because in a society in which
people read, the big
lies of demagogues
can't stand, because we
can tell ourselves using
data and facts and even our own
feelings that they're wrong,
that it's not true.
It's why in
totalitarian societies
they either destroy
or control books,
because they don't want
people to have access
to that kind of information.
And the other thing is, it's
the thing that breaks down
the barriers among us.
I mean, when you read
Jhumpa Lahiri's fiction,
you understand what it's like
to be an Asian immigrant living
in this country.
When you read the "Bluest
Eye" by Toni Morrison,
you understand what it's
like to be demonized simply
because you're black.
Men learn what it's like to
be female by reading fiction,
women what it's like to be male.
So writing makes
us feel less alone.
Because not only do we read
other people's stories,
but in their stories
we discover ourselves.
And in our society
today to feel less alone
is the single most
important thing, I think,
that anything can do for us.
And books do it over
and over and over again.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do
you think that-- this
is a question that I think
applies to Google somewhat
as a technology company.
Do you think there's a trade-off
between either technology
and our humanity?
As we have more
access to people,
are we becoming more lonely?
ANNA QUINDLEN: You
know, I don't think
it has to be an either/or.
I think sometimes
it feels that way.
I was keenly aware
of it one day and how
it didn't impinge this
important part of my life
when I was walking through
the park, and in front of me
was a woman who had
probably a two-year-old,
a two-year-old little
girl in a stroller.
And the two-year-old little
girl was facing the woman.
And she was doing all
the things two-year-olds
try to do to say hey, I'm here,
I'm alive, engage with me.
And the woman was
looking at her iPhone.
And at first I was appalled.
And then I thought,
if I had been
born at a slightly different
time, that would have been me.
So I think that we have
to control tech rather
than letting tech control us.
But I use a lot of tech.
I mean, writing a
novel on a computer,
it makes it so much easier.
It makes the revision
process so much easier.
It doesn't frighten
you about-- look,
there's only one copy of
the manuscript of Dickens'
"A Christmas Carol."
It's in the Morgan
Museum in New York.
If I only had one
copy of my novel,
I would be in a state
of terror constantly.
I have endless copies because
of the backup systems I have.
So I think tech can
be of enormous value.
But I think that we have
to learn to control it.
It's like people ask me all the
time about journalism and news
gathering in this society.
And what I always
say is that it's
possible to be better
informed in America today
than at any time in the
history of this country,
because you don't have to rely
on one local newspaper, one
evening newscast.
You can watch the BBC.
You can read "The Guardian."
You can read "The Times."
you can read "The Wall Street
Journal" no matter where you
are in the country or the world.
You can read Buzzfeed.
You can read Politico.
You can be a hunter gatherer
of news for yourself.
But that means you need to
be an educated consumer.
You need to be thoughtful
about what you're doing
and where you're getting
your information from.
Ditto with tech.
You just have to be thoughtful
about what you're doing
and how you're doing it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do
you mind if I-- just
back to the importance
the written word.
And you've written
a bit and you've
spoken about your frustrations
with this election cycle.
Sort of what lines do
you think there needs
to be between being
polite, being honest,
can you explain some
of your thoughts
and your frustrations
and your feelings
about what's going on now?
ANNA QUINDLEN: I think
public civility is important.
I think that you can have an
animated exchange of ideas
between people with vastly
different worldviews
without using the language
of middle school bullying.
I think that's really important.
I mean, take an example.
In the "NewsHour"
from time to time
they have David Brooks
and E.J. Dionne talking
about the issues of the day.
They have quite different
political viewpoints.
And they often differ
greatly, but never impolitely.
And that doesn't mean either
of them pulls their punches.
It just means that they're
trying to produce light and not
just heat.
This has been an election
cycle in which it's
been heat, heat, more heat.
And at the end of, quite
frankly, the GOP debates,
I don't think there's been a
single debate where at the end
I think I've learned
something about a subject.
I learned things about how the
men involved saw one another
or saw themselves.
But in terms of data points,
in terms of saying gee,
I didn't really understand that
about the minimum wage or I
hadn't quite taken that into
account in our trade agreements
with China, not
a moment of that.
And you know, this
country needs that.
I'm willing to honor
the fact that there
are people who are
not like me, liberals,
thoughtful conservatives
who would say to me,
no Anna, that's not how
we should do things.
But not if they
call me an idiot,
and not if I call them an idiot.
That's not how we
ought to resolve
the very substantial
issues that affect us
at this point in time.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I would like
to open it up to audience
questions if anyone has any.
If you would wait for the
mic to come back to you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for an enlightening
interview so far.
I really liked your
comment about how
writing was also about writing
when you didn't want to write.
And my question to
you on that was,
what do you write about when
you don't want to write,
but you know you need to write?
And when you look
back on what you
wrote when you didn't want
to write but you did write,
do you like what you see?
Is it still as good?
Or can you tell
that you didn't want
to write when you wrote what
you wrote when you didn't
want to write what you wrote?
ANNA QUINDLEN: I feel like
we're doing Peter Piper picked
a peck of pickled peppers.
I have this little trick
that's really helped
me get over the hump each time.
And it's this.
I never knock off for the
day at the end of a chapter.
And I never knock off
at the end of the day
at the end of a paragraph.
I don't even knock off
at the end of a sentence.
I knock off in midsentence.
Because when I come back the
next morning, which is really
when the not wanting to write
is at its highest level, when
the DVR is calling
its siren song to me,
I can always manage to
finish an existing sentence.
I know where the rest
of that sentence goes.
And oftentimes if I can
finish that sentence,
it jump starts me into
another sentence, and then
another, and then another.
And then sometimes what
happens is I'm toodling along,
and I'm not really
firing on all cylinders.
And then I get to a
sentence and I go boom.
In other words,
I find frequently
that halfhearted mediocre
writing done over time
leads to better and
even good writing.
I tend not to look
over my stuff.
I tend to write as fast as I can
to the end of the first draft.
But I can't say that
I've ever gone back,
when I do go back when I've done
that first draft, to read over
again and said oh, I
remember this was a bad day.
What I think you
remember more is
that there is the
occasional day--
and they don't come that often,
but they do come sometimes--
when you're thinking,
I have nothing to say.
You sit down at the computer.
You start to write.
And then you start to type
really, really quickly.
And when you look up,
an hour and a half
has gone by, because
you're totally in the zone.
And that's the best
feeling in the world.
It's really what
keeps you doing this.
And I can always sort of intuit
those scenes when I go back
and read over.
I think yeah, that's a day
when I was really hitting it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Wait for the mic.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for
coming and joining us here.
I was curious about
your relationship
with editors as part
of your writing process
and how that had differed
both when you were working
as a journalist and also just
on for the fiction, and how much
sort of freedom that
you have to push
back and sort of how
important that relationship is
in writing.
ANNA QUINDLEN: I've had a very
interesting career trajectory
in terms of editing because
I've sort of earned the right
to have less and less of it.
For example when I was a young
reporter at "The New York
Times," editors could basically
do what they would to my copy.
And sometimes they did.
And some of the
very good ones got
me to improve my
copy to the point
where they were
satisfied with it.
And of course those are
the really good ones.
And then once I
became a columnist,
columnists at "The
Times" have the right
to be edited as much or as
little as they would like.
So they can say, hands off.
That's incredibly foolish.
It's just incredibly
foolish because you're
good editors are
mirrors of your readers.
And if they're
able to say to you,
this third graph
doesn't quite track
to me, that means that
all over the country,
there would be people
sitting on the subway
or at their breakfast
tables going,
I'm not sure which she
means in that third graph.
And often it's just
a little tweak that
takes it from hmm to oh yeah.
With my novels, I have
been incredibly lucky
because I've had the same editor
for every book I've ever done,
Kate Medina at Random House.
And we really know
how to work together.
And what she does is, once
I finished a first draft,
I then read the
entire book aloud.
It takes about a week.
Because it's by ear that I
can hear what's wrong with it.
I mean if a sentence
is way too long,
I'll know because I can't
breathe by the end of it.
That's nature's way of saying
hello, you need a semicolon.
If a line of dialogue
doesn't work,
when I say it out loud
I think, OK, people
don't really talk like that.
Time to fix that one.
So at the end of
the read through,
I've done some work
on the manuscript.
And then I hand it to Kate.
And about three weeks later,
what I get back from her
is-- I know this is so hard
for me to have to admit,
but she will not
edit except on paper.
It's so frustrating because
I do the whole thing
on the computer.
I send it to her
Then she prints out paper.
And she does annotations
on the manuscript.
And then she sends me about
a 12 to 14 page single space
thing that says, I love Mimi.
I love the relationship
with her and her mother.
This is so interesting.
That's so interesting.
At the beginning of
the book, I think
you need a little less
backstory in the prologue.
Chapter one, that whole scene,
and she goes blow by blow
and says, you
gotta tighten this.
You gotta cut this.
You ought to move this.
I could basically
said, I don't think so.
It's fine the way it is.
I wouldn't do that.
But I would say at this point
I probably implement about 60%
to 70% of what she says.
And then the other,
we just have to agree
to disagree about that.
And it used to be that I'd
go through three drafts.
I'd do that second draft and do
a lot of moving and rewriting.
And then she'd go
over that, and I'd
do kind of a
smoothing third graph.
This is my eighth novel, so
I'm down to just two graphs--
two drafts.
And you know, she always,
in one way or another,
makes the book better.
Because when you're writing a
novel and it's going the way
it should be going, you're
kind of living in it.
I mean, they're very real to you
if you're doing it correctly.
But the end result
of that is you
have almost zero perspective
on it by the end.
I mean, I almost want to
throw it out the window
and hope it gets to Kate,
because I've had it.
Enough.
I can't look at it
one more minute.
And so to have
somebody who knows
you, who knows your work, who
can step back and say, wow,
I love this.
But this all sort of needs to
be sharpened up a little bit.
Someone you trust and have
worked with for a long time
is just an enormous gift.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
curious about the--
you said that op-ed columnists
or just columnists in general
used to be able to push back
as much as much they wanted.
ANNA QUINDLEN: Op
Ed page columnists.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Has that
changed in recent years?
ANNA QUINDLEN: No, I think
it's still pretty-- I mean,
being an op-ed page columnist is
the single most independent job
at the paper.
As the chairman and
publisher explained to me
when he offered me
the job, he would not
be speaking to me
about my column
again unless he fired me.
It's because you're supposed to
be independent, because you're
not supposed to
feel the business
departments or the
editorial departments
or the power structure
of the paper looking
over your shoulder.
That's in the words
of the founder
of the current iteration
of "The New York Times."
You're supposed be able to
write without fear or favor.
And to do that
they feel that you
have to be really independent.
And along with that
you can forego editing.
But I would say it's a
very foolish writer who
forgoes editing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Any
other audience questions?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
What's the most frustrating
part about being a writer?
ANNA QUINDLEN: It's
all pretty frustrating.
Because when you're doing
your walking around time,
you have an ideal in your mind.
I used to think I'd forgot it.
You know, I used to
think I had it nailed,
and somehow I just forgot it.
And what's on the pages is a
slightly less able iteration.
But it turns out that,
in a lot of jobs,
you have this
ideal in your mind.
And then there's always
that slight disconnect
between the ideal and the real.
And I think that's a
frustration that you
feel like-- I was saying
the other day in terms
of how I value tech
for this whole process,
that there was a very
famous writer named
Richard Yates who wrote a novel
called "Revolutionary Road."
And it's a beautiful novel,
widely praised and won prizes.
But he actually had
finished that novel
and there was a
fire at his home.
And the manuscript of
the novel was destroyed.
So he had to start from scratch.
And the book he produced
is a great, great novel.
But he always insisted that
the original was better.
And it seems to me that that's
a reflection of what we always
feel is that disconnect
between the way we see it
in our mind's eye and the way
it actually lays on the page.
And I think that's the
greatest frustration.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] if
you don't mind my asking,
do you think that
it's very [INAUDIBLE]?
ANNA QUINDLEN: I don't know,
because there is that moment
where you're satisfied.
When I've finished
the second draft,
as a hedge against
public opinion, which
can be so punishing
and so powerful,
I again read the novel aloud.
And at the end when I
have satisfied myself
that this is the book
I want to publish,
I actually-- this
sounds so silly,
but it has become kind of an
important spiritual, if you
will, component of this.
I actually say to myself,
this is good work.
And it's really
important because I
can live on that moment
if the book isn't selling
very well, if I hear
that the reviews are bad,
if any of the
negative things that
can be follow the publication
of a book are happening.
I can still remember the
moment where I said to myself,
this is good work.
So obviously there
is that moment
where you're satisfied with
it going out into the world.
But you know, there
are all those stories
about various famous painters
who finish a painting
and then paint over it
again because it's always
the next thing, the next thing.
Maybe it's the essence
of the human condition,
that if we only get
to the next thing,
that will be the right thing.
AUDIENCE: Because your answer's
so authentic [INAUDIBLE].
I appreciate the eloquence with
which you kind of encourage
people who are
thinking about writing
or who want to write
actually [INAUDIBLE].
You spoke earlier about
how one personal challenge
you both have is [INAUDIBLE].
I think another challenge
or personal challenge is,
am I going to be successful?
[INAUDIBLE]
You go to a big tech
company [INAUDIBLE],
even if you're not
great at your job,
you still get the
benefits, still
get to shirk off work
on a Friday [INAUDIBLE].
And there's [INAUDIBLE]
that if I put it
all into a [INAUDIBLE], I'm
not very good, [INAUDIBLE].
Do you have a secret
sauce or any [INAUDIBLE]?
ANNA QUINDLEN: No.
That's why I went into
the newspaper business.
I really wanted
to be a novelist,
but I couldn't
for the life of me
figure out how you
could be a novelist
and make a living at it.
There's no obvious career
path to becoming a writer.
So luckily for me I went
into the newspaper business
originally to pay the rent.
And then I found
it so incredibly
seductive and rewarding that
I just stayed and stayed
and stayed and stayed.
So the answer is that some
people who are writers
find straight jobs and
write for an hour every day
either before or after.
Some try to write
for freelance outlets
where they can eke out a
meager living while they're
working on the great book.
And some just
don't do it at all.
I remember at one point--
all three of my children
in various ways are writers.
And at one point, our oldest
son speaks fluent Mandarin.
And his father
suggested that he go
to work for one of the big
investment banks in Beijing,
and he could do
that for 10 years
and stockpile enough
money to live on and work
full time as a novelist.
And Quinn said, "Dad,
that's not how it works.
If I take that job,
I'll never leave."
And I think there's a
lot of truth to that.
So it does take guts, and it
takes a belief in yourself.
And it also takes a
willingness, a year or two out,
to say this isn't
working out and I've
got to circle around to
a straighter job again.
I was lucky in that the
job I found to get me here
was a job that helped
me do what I do here,
and also one that just fed my
soul every day that I did it
as a reporter.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
have another question.
Are there parts of your public
identity I guess as a writer
that you are particularly proud
of and parts that you're, no, I
don't want to be known
as that, or I don't
want to be known like that?
ANNA QUINDLEN: Well
my public identity
as a writer is
really bifurcated.
As a journalist, I'd like to
think as a columnist that I did
would H.L. Mencken once said
a good columnist should do,
and that is to "afflict
the comfortable and comfort
the afflicted."
I was intensely interested
in the issues that affect
the poorest American citizens.
And I wrote about them
over and over again.
And I hope that maybe
in some small corners
I made a difference.
And as a novelist, people will
tell me over and over again
that I did make them feel more
connected to their deepest
selves, I mean, sometimes
in really profound
and specific ways.
I wrote a novel called "Black
and Blue" about a nurse
who is married to a police
officer who beats her,
and who flees from
him with their son.
And a woman told me that she
called 911 for the first time
while she was holding the book.
And you know, if
that doesn't make
you feel both significant
and small at the same time,
then nothing else will.
Or women whose mother died when
they were younger, as mine did,
and as I reflected both in
nonfiction and in fiction,
feel some kind of an
affinity for me and my work.
And I'm happy for that
part of the public persona.
I hate the part of the public
persona that's distancing,
that makes it sound
as though somehow I
have some special gift.
I mean, so much of this is
just pushing the rock uphill.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Time for
another question or two
if anyone else
has any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] today.
I wonder if you could talk
a little bit about your kind
of daily writing process.
I rented a cottage
way up in the hills,
thought it would be great
to give myself two years
to work on a book project.
And I am so easily distracted
and profoundly committed
to procrastination,
it's blowing my mind.
ANNA QUINDLEN: OK, ditto.
So here's my deal.
First of all the only way
that I can work successfully
is to have an incredibly
boring set to music life.
I don't travel a whole lot.
My social life is kind
of-- Edna O'Brien,
the great Irish novelist,
just had this incredible quote
in "The Times" where she said
something about "the real life
is back at the desk."
And I knew exactly
what she meant.
She was lamenting how hard it
is for your life because so much
of where you are is
in this other world.
So I have a whole
routine every morning
which is designed to
prevent me from writing.
So first I have breakfast.
Then I have this hour's
worth of aerobics exercise.
Then I read four newspapers.
Then I talk to my best
friend on the telephone.
Then depending on-- I'll
fold towels if I-- the thing
is, I run out of stuff at
about 9:30 in the morning.
And that's the moment when I
just give up and go upstairs
to my office.
And then once I go to
my office, I sort of
say OK, you can't
leave until lunch time,
and just sit there and do it.
And then I come down and
have lunch usually with my--
or often with my eldest,
who also works in our house.
And then I usually go back
upstairs for an hour or two
afterwards.
I can't work on a novel more
than two or three hours a day,
not because I can't write more
than that, because there were
days when I was a
columnist or a reporter
when I would write for
eight, 10, 12 hours straight.
It's the imagination
starts to dull over time.
And so then I will work on
answering emails or writing
speeches or things like that.
And then the next
day, midsentence, I
start up and do it again.
But life has to be really
boring, not a whole lot
of dinner invitations.
If you want to
meet me for a meal
to talk about business,
which I actually
do with some regularity,
it has to be breakfast
because I can't go into
that belly of the day
or I've lost the whole day.
I really have to have
those three or four
hours just chunked out there.
And sometimes it's
better not to do it
in some nice little cottage
out in the middle of nowhere,
although I do do
that in the summer.
We have a weekend
house and that's
where I live during the summer
and I have this little shack
kind of thing that
I built out there.
But sometimes it's
important to just
have a regular daily
routine with writing
smack dab in the middle.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All
right, one last question.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
just given up on a novel?
Or let's see even
a column, realize
that it wasn't happening,
the story didn't make sense,
or rather it just
didn't complete itself?
Or do you always push
through and then decide
what to do with it?
ANNA QUINDLEN: Actually
I have one novel
that died on the vine.
It would have been my third.
And I wrote the draft.
And I was happy with it.
And my agent and my editor
were both happy with it.
And so my editor sent
me all the things
that I described to you earlier
for the editing process.
And what I found is no matter
how much I worked on it,
I didn't make it better.
I made it worse.
I made it flatter.
As opposed to coming to life,
the life drained out of it
is what it came down to.
And I handed in the
revisions to my editor
and she knew the same thing.
And there was a moment when
she called me and asked if we
could have lunch with my agent.
And I knew that it
was the being called
to the principal's office call.
It was the, this is not
working very well call.
But luckily before they
could say anything, I said,
I've already
started a new novel.
It's about a nurse whose husband
is a cop who beats her up.
And it's called
"Black and Blue."
And you could see both of them
just let out a sigh of relief
that we didn't have to
have that conversation.
In the years since,
I've decided and I've
realized in conversation
with some of my colleagues
that that novel is what I
think of as a chop shop novel.
In other words, there are
various elements of it
that I've used for other books.
There are sort of variations
of characters that were in it
that have popped up in
other novels and settings
and so on and so forth.
And it appears
from conversations
I've had like there's
a lot of us who
have that kind of book
somewhere, the book that didn't
quite work, but which can
be used inspirationally
to get you going on other books.
So it would be
completely unusable now
because I've chopped it up so
much and used it elsewhere.
But it was a valuable lesson.
And it was a valuable
lesson to learn
early on, because clearly one
of the things I said to myself
was, this isn't working.
Therefore I have to
start immediately
on something
completely different
to get the motor running again.
AUDIENCE: All right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ANNA QUINDLEN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: You see a lot of
posthumously published works.
Even if you think
you've chopped it up,
have you put any kind of
a prohibition in place
to prevent that from
ever being published?
ANNA QUINDLEN: I actually have
a very fine literary executor
to whom I gave birth 32 years
ago who understands completely
how the world of
publishing works
and who knows me
down to the ground.
And we had an
animated conversation
about this when "Go Set a
Watchman" was published,
because I was kind
of horrified by that.
I'm quite convinced that
that was a chop shop novel
and that it wound
up giving birth
to one of the transcendent books
of the 20th century, "To Kill
a Mockingbird."
And Quinn understands very
well that if it didn't
see the light of
day when I wrote it,
there's a reason for that.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you very much.
ANNA QUINDLEN: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And I
think-- are you available
for a few minutes
afterwards for book signing?
ANNA QUINDLEN: Sure.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All
right, thank you.
ANNA QUINDLEN: Thanks.